hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to explain the 80/20 rule
which is also known as the Pareto
principle the 80/20 rule states that 80%
of the results come from 20% of the
causes it was observed in 1906 by the
economist vilfredo pareto who noticed
that 80% of the land in Italy was owned
by only 20% of the population the 80/20
rule has many examples for instance 80%
of the world income comes from 20% of
the richest people the 80/20 rule is a
good rule of thumb so that you can focus
on only 20% of the causes to improve 80%
of the results but why does it happen
let's do an experiment to find out we'll
start our experiment with a hundred
paper clips well mix them into a pile
and select two paper clips at random
well join those paper clips into a chain
and then we'll put them back into the
pile we'll repeat the experiment by
selecting two paper clips at random and
joining them into a chain we'll repeat
this experiment over and over again each
time joining paper clips into chains if
we selected them randomly over time
there will be some chains of paperclips
which get very long in fact chains which
are longer will be more likely to get
picked and they'll form even longer
chains after we repeat this experiment
over and over again we can look at the
distribution of paperclip chains because
the longer chains are more likely to get
picked this is an example of how the
rich can get richer in our distribution
of paperclip chains there will be many
paper clips that are single and by
themselves and a few paper clips which
are very long chains and this is where
the 80/20 rule can be Illustrated 80% of
the paperclips belong to the top 20% of
the longest chains in fact if we were to
graph out the data we would find what's
known as a power law where there are a
lot of paper clips that of a very small
size but there are a few paper clips
that have very high valued size and take
up a majority of the
paperclips this type of graph is also
seen with income distribution now we
know why the 80/20 rule happens it's an
emergent phenomenon from a process where
ever the rich get richer the 80/20 rule
is also a pretty good rule of thumb for
efficiency I hope you like this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
support mind your decisions on patreon
and get exclusive rewards you can catch
me on my blog mind your decisions on
Twitter at pressure Locker or get my
books at Amazon